how's it going guys today and we're
gonna be reacting to Joshua flukes new
video descent seven sinful words of the
industry programmer elitism
I don't normally react videos but since
this is specific to programmers and I'm
sort of a programmer lifer thought I'd
react give my opinion and maybe it'll
help somebody out there once again he
was mad watching KOAT acting toriel's
and I just want to say off the bat that
I like Josh I got no problems with him
but you know I just want to be honest
and just share a point of view that
might be slightly missed in this video
so here we go let's just watch I'll
pause a few times
reddit programmer look at that overflow
Stack Overflow repkin reverse open
Christmas silver and legally
all right first of all I want to say I'm
not a big fan of CS career questions
I've looked at as hominis been helpful
in some points but I don't I don't
subscribe to their credit right anymore
I read it whatever I've read it as yeah
you get some good info but you gotta be
careful there as with anywhere you know
it's kind of in general the Internet
was a Tesla charges a Starbucks caffeine
only diet put zoom on meetings zoom
meetings on speaker why the heck do
people do that publicly I don't think
you know I've only seen one person ever
do that so I think people most people
are smart enough to yeah I think most
people are smart enough to wear
headphones when they're on a meeting it
so it's only the person that's like
their first time on whatever that they
don't use headphones
and also I think this is a bit
unrealistic - I don't think most
programmers or people really care where
you want to work to be honest I've never
really heard anyone be too concerned
ever until here this is the first time I
heard someone extremely busy remote
developer completes two tickets for what
lasts all sunlight 94 days ago currently
it's telling Valery GrubHub
really focused lately the dog the dog
was perfect timing
look at this personally I am team try
and organically forest the UI UX guy no
further information you did
excuse me so weird I knew a few guys
like this when I was in computer science
they were strictly all about the ui/ux
and I don't know they weren't all that
passionate about coding and I didn't
understand why they were in computer
science really but whatever matter it
appears there is a new post of someone
who doesn't want to work at Google he
must drink the chai the current theme is
kool-aid
you see if you say those words this is
great so far I love the skit format of
these and you're in tech you're
basically a loser
this is inaccurate right off the bat
um like I said earlier not yeah
everybody wants to work at those I I
really don't know a lot of people that
do say they want to work at one of those
companies honestly most of them are too
concerned and I will say you know this
is not entirely on topic but and I'm not
trying to brag but I've had some I've
had several instances where I've had
opportunities to interview for Google
and a couple other big companies Amazon
and I I feigned interest when they first
talked to me but I wasn't interested in
I don't honestly know why other than I
didn't feel like traveling so I think
that's pretty common actually I think
it's usually only the people that you
know they just want the best job
possible and don't really have any
interest in starting their own thing
usually they want you know they go for
one of these companies because they have
the best package and that's fine yeah
elitism and the culture it doesn't mean
you're an elitist and we want to work on
one of these companies all it means is
other people have recognized your skill
and that's something you know people
like having their skill recognized and
it's yeah it's just it's just a matter
like a merit badge
it doesn't hurt it's cool it generally
means they're pretty good at coding our
engineering is what's what's wrong with
that but yeah you don't have to have it
you could just show a project that says
the same thing and it's about same hey I
don't I don't have any grand experience
other than oh I I don't think don't know
why some of these big companies contact
me sometimes and I'm often surprised but
also I don't I don't know like I don't
know what to make of that really the
quality of dev you are does not have to
do with where you work
Yeah right I'm not being sarcastic
that's just inherently true that is not
everyone's dreams yeah we know well no
one should be saying that if that's not
you dreaming on a real developer that's
I've never heard anybody say that I
don't think that's the thing can confirm
I have seen some terrible devs at places
I've worked and I could not understand
how they work there but I don't know
they seem to get by okay and also that
was just my opinion I didn't like some
of them might have never code with I
just had the impression that they
weren't the greatest debt but I could
have been wrong I don't know relative to
being able to provide value to the
product that you're working on and
having the flexibility to solve problems
related to it that is what makes you a
good
and I know that's gonna trigger a bunch
of people I don't think it's gonna
trigger a bunch of people other than
there just can be like holy we know
because they've idolized this idea that
where you work
defines who you are that your job title
defines who you are it is true that
sometimes your job title does define who
you are and it's not necessarily
anything wrong with that but yeah it's
not how it really is in general and they
use it to elevate themselves above other
people yeah that's that's how you give
prestigious positions you have a really
good CV or a prestigious CV you know
that's that's what draws interest here
it doesn't mean you're better than
anybody it just means you have some
experience and some proof that you're at
least half decent that's that's all it
really means it doesn't mean you're
better than anybody anybody can do that
anybody can build up their history
through you know repetition and being
consistent like even even some random
person watching this that thinks I'll
never make it I guarantee you can if you
just stay consistent keep working on
your skills day to day I did not start
programming till I was 31 years old and
I'm I don't know it's fine I didn't
start playing guitar and music too I was
20 and I thought that was late too and
you know it was like a few years later
people were just like whoa have you
played since you were a kid namely and
no it's just cuz I was dedicated so it's
more about dedication than it is about
anything else is that people use the
company that they work for as like oh
look at me I'm here you know like not
everyone wants to work there not
everyone wants to relocate not everyone
is passionate about the products at
these places because at the end of the
day that's what really matters ever
actually I think people are passionate
about the project the products at these
places because
okay or at 3:59 I'll go back but
maybe Josh doesn't realize that he's
passionate about it because all of us
use Google every day pretty much where
is it
giggles searched in the front of this in
the first part of this anyway my point
is we need these services and we need
good people working on them otherwise we
wouldn't use the services so in a way
we're all kind of passionate about these
I see so many people creating their life
around their job rather than creating
the job around their life okay whatever
works for you it doesn't it doesn't
matter yeah I don't think you should
move for a job and I don't know I mean
it doesn't matter what do you mean you
should be it it just it doesn't matter
it's your opinion on this doesn't matter
every individual person can make their
own decision on this stop talking move
on next point we all we all know that we
only get one light actually we don't all
know some people think they get multiple
lives oddly enough I've heard that over
your job there are good devs Google
quality devs Netflix quality devs
Facebook quality devs at other places
besides Fang companies but up here just
have this press fusion about them but
not ever yeah well I guess I guess I'd
just be repeating myself at this point
maybe I already kind of covered that and
that's what's really difficult for
people to understand but what really
matters is if you're passionate about
your job do you care about what you're
building or you just want the prestige
of being part of the company that's
actually a good point are you passionate
about what you're building or do you
just want the prestige of being there or
whatever
a bit of a tricky one because I think
we're a lot of people was both like yeah
they want to build up their resume so
they keep getting better jobs and better
recognition and stuff you know people
like being recognized there's everyone
does Hank that's that's probably why
Josh does YouTube to some extent his
further recognition you know it's great
videos all I cared about was wanting to
be able to wake up and have some control
over what I was doing with my life okay
yeah you don't have to prove anything
anyone if you don't want to and you do
have control everybody has control of
their life whether they realize it or
not sometimes it's brutal sometimes you
might be stuck in some sort of scenario
where someone else is trying to control
you or something but you still have
choices you can fight you can resist
it's all it's all your call probably not
really honestly I just can't bring
myself to care about it in the interview
I will tell you that I care about it in
the interview I will say yes 100% I am
passionate about what you're building
here mainly because I'm passionate about
paying my bill okay that's sort of a red
flag in an interview then unfortunately
because it's again I explained this I've
been considering posting a few openings
for something I'm working on and I've
done interviews with people before and
interviewed people and it's always very
obvious when someone says they're all in
and they love it just because they want
the job and they want to get your
accepted for this position so he's
pretty obvious not at first but after
you've been around the walk a little he
becomes pretty obvious because yeah it
just shows like the person who says
they're passionate they'll show up and
not really care they they'll pretend to
care when you're around but as soon as
you're not around they don't really care
and it's like they're just only trying
to impress the boss to keep the job
that's not what the boss wants you have
to understand that usually when you get
hired for something it's for the results
right and if you're passionate about it
that's even better because then you're
someone they you know they can talk to
about it and you guys can have you know
you can build up a relationship often
around the product you're working on and
you know make friends that way or
whatever this is a tricky one to talk
about but yeah I think I leave it at
that so much for not wanting to work at
any of these companies for not wanting
to work I was not aware of that I've
heard some people complain and like I
even said in one of my videos like like
one of the responses from earlier or
whatever I said when I say I said
something like sure yeah I would like
josh's channel to be about code but I
would like all channels to be about code
because that's just what I'm interested
in you know I don't I don't care I like
it I like this channel the way it is
though it's fine it's good it's good
content I think a lot of people it's
that way actually that's that's probably
pretty common and it's like yeah you
want to be part of something bigger than
yourself you want to be able to
contribute and often being able to
contribute is yeah you got to be better
than the average person because you know
you're building something special needs
some special attention sort of thing
something like that when I say things
like I don't want to work at a fan
company I don't want to live in Silicon
Valley I don't want to live in New York
City I don't care about what these
people are making I don't care about the
prestige of it on my resume there's
nothing wrong with that that's fine
so mind-blowing to me I don't seem cheap
I don't you know it's fine you don't
have to care about that a Stoke that's
the real thing you're just you're just
not a real dev you're just too dumb hi
if someone's saying that they probably
don't understand something I don't know
they might be missing something but I
don't think that and I don't I don't
think most people think that I doubt
you're the only youtuber think it's a
bunch of crap for you to talk to
scammers all day as an old lady alright
let's just say that okay you know that's
fine Kip bogan doesn't have to be a
software dev and Kip boga what he does
is a great service to everyone his
Hanna's hilarious to watch oh you know
why would anyone why would you expect
anyone to give him crap for that are you
just saying it saying that because you
think you get a lot crap for that I
don't know I might be missing something
but I've never heard of anyone giving
Joshua fluke crap for not being a dev
I've heard people mention that he
doesn't do it anymore but that's not
giving him crap that's just saying hey
doesn't do it anyway yeah that's that's
not giving someone crap someone says to
me that you don't code as much as you
used to
I wouldn't say stop giving me crap I
would just I don't know take it for what
it is I would say yeah I've been a
little busy with other things
but I still like coding you know that's
you know I didn't I'm not sure what the
point here is but let's continue okay
yeah everybody loves Kip bow go because
he's freaking hilarious what he does he
does it a masterful level and it's it's
great that's why would that ever be a
problem not a very good example don't
know Cody Co is videos I have no idea
that guy's job as a programmer and I say
this is the reality of it and it's kind
of funny it's kind of harsh and you
should be aware
that's fine nothing wrong with it you're
always gonna get some flak there's
always gonna be people that don't like
what you do or you know to some extent
you gotta have some credits critics if
there were no critics that's that's a
problem - it's like the 100% positive
feedback flaw if you see something that
has a hundred percent positive reviews
you know that something's wrong with it
because it's like all their friends or
some BOTS or whatever given it all under
percents yeah and not everybody's gonna
agree and there's nothing wrong with
that that doesn't mean they're right
either so don't take it personally all
right let's let's be straight about
something here programming is actually
quite hard especially when you get into
an industry that demands somewhat of
perfection and that sort of thing and
things done quickly
it's hard it's actually really hard one
of the first jobs I had after I
graduated was very stressful to me
because the level difficulty I could
walk through all the code I could
explain everything it's probably why I
got the job honestly is just because I
seemed to understand everything about
what was going on when I was walking
through code but when it came down to
like implementing new features it was
really hard it was I had to go so many
levels deep and there were quite a few
times where I was pretty sure I was
gonna get fired because I couldn't get
stuff done as quickly as I wanted to and
that they wanted me to but I didn't I
I was just open and honest with
everybody and I didn't really
really live up to their expectations
we'll say but I was still able to
provide value and some of that value I
think was helping management understand
better expectations for new depths
coming in because there was like this
expectation that I was gonna be like a
wizard and fix everything and make
everything better very quickly and that
just wasn't reasonable for like such a
large code base so as I was doing things
I had to ask a lot of questions I had to
step back and say oh wait a big part of
it was I was so new to the organization
that I didn't want to do things that
were like against their norm or
something like that it's kind of hard to
explain but basically I had a bit of
anytime I was going to implement
something new I was always hesitating
like is this what etc etc is this what
whoever once is is this what they expect
and that would slow me down a lot but
we'll just say it's hard any programming
is pretty hard it's uh it can be easy it
probably gets easier the more
experienced you get but it hasn't really
happened for me it's still hard and I
still enjoy it I like really difficult
things though I like being challenged ok
let him give you crap that's fine take
the good from the crap you can and
discard the rest no big deal I much
rather work at a no-name mom-and-pop
shop building some little tiny thing
that I can be a part of the huge
Corporation for the prestige of it on my
resume ok there's nothing wrong with
that and sometimes building something
new for some small company is just as
prestigious there's there's nothing
wrong with that I don't want to lead a
corporation I don't want to make a
corporation I don't want to lead all
these people but I also don't want to be
led by anybody ok that's fine let's I
don't understand the problem
yeah so wait a minute though there
that inherently I don't know just try to
unpack that a little bit is that like
saying you only want to work alone you
don't want to work for people or by
people or poor port what I'm not sure
that that's just sort of anti team
environment I don't know I don't know
how to really I don't know if he's just
saying that to get a reaction or or what
but being a solo dev is hard but given
that he's making YouTube videos for
thousands and thousands people I would I
would say that's not entirely true
there's there's some aspect of Josh
wanting to lead I think a lot of people
could probably see that and that's one
of the things with leaders some leaders
don't want to be leaders and maybe Josh
is that sort of guy so sort of
interesting a rogue agent and I'm not
saying that other people should be like
me I'm just saying that you should think
for yourself and here's some information
about entrepreneurship and here's some
information about corporate yeah that's
cool and we I think everyone appreciates
all this info before crossing the road
and I don't think that you should let
the elitism kind of get to you pick a
job that you like and ignore everything
else don't ignore everything else
there's a you gotta take in things so
you can't just ignore everything
some of it you guess you have to discard
a lot of it because it doesn't work for
you or you know it's wrong or whatever
but you should not ignore everything
obviously I mean you use Google you
probably use Netflix too but even in
this video he used Google of course you
have nothing it's Google if you did then
be weird yeah you do
you googled earlier in the video you
care about the products they're building
been coding and I've said this a few
times and it's not to offend anybody
it's just to say but I'm not passionate
about it and that's fine yeah that is
fine you don't have to be passionate
about it doesn't matter how they do they
do and there's a reason you know yeah
everybody always not everybody a lot of
people always I've idolized the top tier
like everybody I keep saying everybody
but I don't mean everybody when I say
everybody I mean a lot of people when I
say everybody a lot of people
we'll always idolized the top of
whatever you know the number-one player
in any game any sport any mini band any
any song yeah that's that's just how it
works
the top-tier stuff is you know it's
something that's obvious to strive for
when you're new it's like okay
I'm new how do i how do I actually
improve my skills well these guys are
obviously really good and let's aim for
that boom so that's that's all really is
you want those credits for me I'd never
needed that pat on the back okay I never
felt the need to wait I thought you said
you'd wait just hearing some
contradictions don't feel a need to be
part of something bigger than yourself
okay well let's just move on I'm not
anyways I just think that people end up
identifying with their degree in their
job title so much
I don't know if I want to comment on
that but okay I mean there's nothing
wrong with that what's the I don't
understand the problem here I'm not I'm
not entirely sure what the point of this
is other than to call something out that
isn't how it is I'm a little bit
confused by the whole thing but let's
continue wait a second
okay this is why people get mad at you
people don't get mad at you for the
ending the other stuff you said but just
now you said and anyways I just think
that people end up identifying with
their degree in their job title so much
that they forget who they are as a
person and they forget what they really
wanted to do before they gave up in life
that right there
that's probably why people get mad in
rage at Josh mo fluke sure he's making a
video and he's sort of making his point
but there there was just like sort of a
passive aggressive attack yet like
anybody who strives to be in one of
these big companies has given up on life
which is a ridiculous statement if you
think about it it's like why why
wouldn't you edit that out honestly
that's that's a pretty abysmal thing to
say if you mean that and I know I'll
probably get flack for that whatever but
it it even contradicts the rest of the
the video so know people aren't mad at
you because you're no one's mad at you
because you don't software dev anymore
or whatever they're probably mad because
you say stuff like that just just saying
I mean that's that's my thoughts on that
corporate stereotypes or developer
stereotypes yes please more skits the
sarcastic stuff at the beginning was
great I loved it yeah that was funny
thumbs up if you didn't double smash
thumbs down let me know you hated it
leave a comment and let me know what you
think about engineering elitism and all
this garbage about how people idolize
these things if you want to work there
that's great again if you want ok what
if you want to work there that's great
but it also means you gave up online in
life so you can't win with this sort of
attitude that's part of the problem here
I see you might be in a negative cycle
we all are there sometimes I've been
there hope you can find some closure or
whatever it may be might always get
phone calls when I'm recording
alright that's gonna do it for this
video that's gonna do it for this video
thank you for tuning in I'm sure the
rest is just natural well let's watch it
okay I'm still annoyed that at this
video there's some links down there in
the description to support the channel
I'll see you guys I am ethically and
organically thor's this ui/ux
artsy tights dude for real this is what
it's like this is what they all have
their little whiteboard with their
creativity and their little little
doodles on it and they're always like
love it's funny I haven't actually seen
anyone quite like that but that's pretty
funny we also have team macho okay
goodbye